[Música]
soy catherine nicolle son bienvenidos a
la entrevista de france 24 hoy
hablaremos con el hombre encargado de la
política exterior de la unión europea
ex ministro de asuntos exteriores de
españa el vicepresidente de la comisión
europea tú se aburren
pueda aburrir muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros gracias a ustedes empecemos
con la estrategia europea de vacunación
enfrenta críticas puede ir demasiado
despacio tanto de externos como de
internos recientemente del canciller de
austria sebastián course
la comisión europea firmó los contratos
de la vacuna y está supervisando el
proceso está de acuerdo con ursula von
der leyen quien dice que la comisión
está siendo utilizada como chivo
expiatorio o le debería estar yendo
mejor a la unión europea con las vacunas
por su poder de negociación
siendo mejor cuál es el porcentaje de la
población británica que ha recibido dos
dosis no una sino dos porque una dosis
no es suficiente
5.5 por ciento y cuál es el porcentaje
de la población europea que ha recibido
dos dosis 5.5 por ciento es lo mismo
sólo que ellos escogieron otra
estrategia vacunar a todo el mundo con
una sola dosis a diferencia de nosotros
que estamos vacunando con dos dosis como
se requiere se segundo hemos exportado
al reino unido- 20 millones de dosis
cuántas dosis se han exportado desde
reino unido hacia europa 0
eeuu hacia el resto del mundo
pero hay que medir las cosas en términos
homogéneos porque si no se confunde a
las personas y si hay retrasos
si hay una campaña que no ha podido
cumplir con sus compromisos
pero ahora mismo estamos impulsando la
capacidad industrial de europa y
estableceremos el objetivo de tener al
75 por ciento de la población vacunada
para el verano
y hace poco los líderes nacionales de la
unión europea acordaron bloquear las
exportaciones de las vacunas bajo
ciertas circunstancias qué piensas sobre
los comentarios de jean claude juncker
de que la unión europea corre el riesgo
de dañar su reputación si se involucra
en una guerra de la vacuna como lo que
muchos realmente me sorprende que pueda
hablar sobre una guerra de la vacuna
quien está peleando esa guerra
como dije nosotros la unión europea
hemos exportado al resto del mundo casi
la misma cantidad de vacunas que le
hemos distribuido a nuestra población le
hemos dado a los ciudadanos europeos 88
millones de dosis y hemos exportado 77
millones de dosis
por favor compare con reino unido y eeuu
que han exportado 0 quien está haciendo
la guerra no no estamos prohibiendo las
exportaciones simplemente estamos
dispuestos a controlar
cuando una compañía no está en la
capacidad de cumplir con sus compromisos
y es seguir exportando al resto del
mundo debemos controlar lo que está
pasando pero eso no significa que
prohibiremos las exportaciones en todas
partes
pasemos a temas de política exterior ha
habido más violencias en mianmar la
unión europea ya impuso sanciones pero
como lo dije ha habido más violencia
desde entonces y eso tal vez pone en
cuestión la efectividad de esas
sanciones habrá más acciones por parte
de la unión europea
qué tipo de acciones
tenemos las herramientas que tenemos
podemos imponer sanciones lo hacemos a
las personas a los responsables a los
militares a las personas físicas y ahora
sancionaremos económicamente al conjunto
a las compañías que poseen los militares
esas son nuestras herramientas podría
imaginarse que enviaría más tropas a
mianmar no entonces usaremos las
herramientas que tenemos y al mismo
tiempo presionaremos diplomáticamente
con las personas del sudeste asiático y
con las naciones unidas porque lo que
está ocurriendo en miramar es una
vergüenza es una vergüenza para la
humanidad es una represión brutal yo he
hecho puedo decir lo mismo para etiopía
y debemos usar las herramientas que
tenemos y rusia tiene una última
relación con mi arma dice que quiere
fortalecer los vínculos con la junta
puede haber presión efectiva europea e
internacional
si rusia está apoyando el golpe militar
en mianmar lo apoya bastante no sólo
políticamente sino también militarmente
eso demuestra en qué posición se
encuentra rusia demuestra que valores
está defendiendo rusia demuestra que hay
un enfoque totalmente distinto de los
derechos humanos en el mundo y por
supuesto eso afectará nuestra relación
hablando de rusia usted viajó
recientemente a moscú para discutir las
relaciones entre la unión europea y
rusia-
pero mientras estaba allí rusia expulsó
a varios diplomáticos de la unión
europea le dijeron que la unión europea
es un aliado poco confiable muchos en
europa lo consideraron un desastre más
de 80 miembros del parlamento europeo le
pidieron personalmente a usted que
renunciara después del viaje
en retrospectiva cree que fue
contraproducente
cuántos miembros tiene el parlamento
europeo
cuántos miembros 780 de 700 es más o
menos un 10% no es significativo
considera entonces que el viaje fue un
éxito por favor mencioné toda la
historia pero considera que el viaje fue
un éxito
no he dicho eso no he dicho eso no no
fue un éxito pero creo que ha habido
cierta exageración al respecto que
habría sido un éxito nunca pretendí ir a
moscú y llevarme a naval ni a casa en mi
equipaje el propósito era evaluar cuál
era la actitud de rusia respecto a la
unión europea y la respuesta fue clara
ciertamente rusia decidió agredir al
expulsar a los diplomáticos europeos
mientras se llevaba a cabo la visita lo
cual va en contra de cualquier
comportamiento diplomático pero por dios
fue culpa de rusia no fui yo quien
expuso a los diplomáticos europeos fue
rusia
y otro lugar donde rusia tiene mucha
influencia es siria ya pasaron 10 años
de guerra en seria la unión europea
organizó una gran conferencia de
donantes y esta semana sin embargo
políticamente parecería que la unión
europea no es un actor en cuanto a lo
que está ocurriendo en siria a
diferencia de rusia o turquía está de
acuerdo con que la unión europea ha
perdido influencia en siria
rusia y turquía han estado enviando
tropas a siria
muchas han usado la fuerza aérea han
bombardeado y destruido combatido matado
y ciertamente eso da más ventaja que
cuando no se interviene militarmente si
la unión europea no ha intervenido
militarmente en siria reino unido- lo ha
hecho eeuu lo ha hecho no hemos apoyado
a las personas en siria con mucho dinero
25.000 millones de euros durante los
últimos 10 años de guerra y seguiremos
haciéndolo puedo decirles que
mantendremos nuestro apoyo financiero
para la población siria y nuestro apoyo
político para reconstruir un país que ha
sido destruido por la guerra por diez
años de guerra haciendo posible que
estas personas regresen a su casa
y hablando de los refugiados sirios
muchos de ellos están actualmente en
turquía otra relación clave para la
unión europea ha habido muchas tensiones
durante el último año
recientemente las cosas se han
tranquilizado
los presidentes von der leyen y michel
irán pronto turquía
ahora en relación con ese viaje rights
watch le escribió usted hace poco
diciendo que creían que el tema de los
abusos a los derechos humanos en turquía
había estado muy ausente de las
reuniones de alto nivel de la unión
europea con las autoridades de turquía
esos líderes europeos abordarán esa
situación con el presidente ortega como
lo piden human rights watch
están hablando sobre todo lo que es
importante para nuestra relación por
supuesto que la situación interna en
turquía es un punto de preocupación pero
también hay otros y tenemos que
tratarlos todos al mismo tiempo debemos
hablar sobre el apoyo a los refugiados
sirios por supuesto debemos hablar sobre
el asentamiento en chipre debemos hablar
sobre las fronteras marítimas en el este
del mediterráneo y la discusión entre
grecia y turquía debemos hablar sobre la
modernización de las aduanas sobre la
liberalización de la visa muchos temas
que pueden servir para construir una
mejor alianza y un mejor vecindario con
turquía porque eso es muchos muchos
asuntos son importantes y nuestras
relaciones exteriores también los son
muchos asuntos que todos conocemos bien
y parece que el problema de la relación
aduanera entre la unión europea y
turquía se discutirá tal vez volviendo a
la estrategia de incentivos human rights
watch dice que los derechos humanos
podrían ser una preocupación secundaria
entre todos estos temas de comercio
geopolítico
y esa es una pregunta a una afirmación
no creo que los derechos humanos sean
una consideración secundaria para
nosotros al contrario los derechos
humanos son una parte muy importante de
nuestra política exterior no creo que
nadie más en el mundo le dé tanta
importancia a los derechos humanos en la
política exterior como lo hacemos
nosotros en la unión europea en turquía
y en todos los otros lugares
última pregunta en relación con los
derechos humanos el consejo europeo
decidió sancionar a china por las
violaciones a los derechos en la
provincia de xinjiang frente a los vélez
pero solo sancionaron unos cuantos
oficiales regionales
espera que esta acción tenga un impacto
más concreto sobre las violaciones de
derechos documentadas contra los buitres
las sanciones tienen la importancia que
tienen
por supuesto no hay una capacidad mágica
para cambiar los comportamientos de
regímenes como china o turquía o rusia a
través de sanciones
pero tenemos las herramientas que
tenemos y las utilizamos por primera vez
usamos nuestro régimen de sanciones de
derechos humanos para luchar contra las
violaciones de los derechos humanos en
yang yang
y como sabes ha habido una reacción
fuerte desproporcionada por parte de
china donde al mismo tiempo tenemos una
relación importante con china en muchos
asuntos y como le dije antes nadie le
presta más atención a los derechos
humanos en el mundo ni los involucra en
su política exterior como nosotros tal
como lo demuestra el hecho de que
hayamos sancionado a los responsables
por el asunto figura en china
rayman gracias a ustedes
[Música]